des montagnes des forêts à perte de vue
loin de l'agitation de la capitale au
nord ouest du pays à la frontière avec
l'algérie
tabarka in drame semble comme figé cette
région de villégiature prisé pour son
calme et son tourisme écologique sombre
jour après jour dans la détresse
économique hôteliers artisans et
commerçants ferment à tour de rôle face
à l'absence de touristes due à la crise
sanitaire du co lead et plus
particulièrement à l'absence des voisins
algériens qui représente près de 50% des
touristes de la région samhi
bendjaballah travaille le bois depuis
plus de dix ans
ces créations artisanales il les vend
sol out point de passage entre l'algérie
et la tunisie depuis près d'un an
ces créations prennent la poussière et
les clients sont devenus très rares
comme beaucoup d'artisans de la région
il craint de devoir fermer boutique
depuis la fermeture des frontières au
mois de mars de l'année dernière notre
activité a énormément baissé
on travaillait beaucoup avec nos voisins
algériens du coup aujourd'hui on
travaille quasiment plus en plus des
algériens on travaille également avec
les touristes étrangers notamment des
européens mais tout ça c'est fini il n'y
a plus de travail
il arrive parfois que je ne demande
aucune pièce pendant toute une semaine
il ne reste aujourd'hui plus que la
patience le nord-ouest compte une
dizaine de grands hôtels qui font vivre
une grande partie de la région depuis la
révolution de 2011 puis la crise du
colline près de quatre grands complexes
ont fermé leurs portes
kamel naïma et leila font partie de ces
dommages collatéraux c'est le coeur
serré et qu'il déambule sur cette
promenade
autrefois bondés de touristes au chômage
technique
il regrette la fermeture des frontières
avec l'algérie nous sommes au chômage
technique depuis septembre et bien avant
septembre même on avait travaillé que
juillet et août depuis le début de la
crise au mois de mars
depuis la fermeture des frontières avec
l'algérie les conséquences se sont
alourdies car les algériens passent
toujours par notre région
pas seulement pour les vacances mais
aussi pour faire leurs achats
et profiter de nos marchés du coup les
magasins fonctionnent les hôtels
fonctionnent et même les petits
commerçants
les épiciers et les vendeurs de légumes
profil de cette clientèle algérienne
depuis cette fermeture les conséquences
sont lourdes pour tout le monde
une situation compliquée pour ces
professionnels du tourisme qui dénonce
l'inaction du gouvernement face à cette
crise économique qui paralyse la région
sur les quatre hôtels qui ont fermé on
ne comptait pas moins de 700 salariés
c'est un secteur qui nourrit beaucoup de
familles ici alors aujourd'hui que fait
le gouvernement où l état il est
complètement absent nous souhaitons que
le chef de gouvernement prenne enfin ses
responsabilités et trouve rapidement une
solution à cette crise que nous vivons
ici depuis la révolution et encore plus
à cause de la clé du coc vide
beaucoup sont au chômage sans aucune
indemnité
du côté des autorités représentées par
l'office du tourisme on en perd pour le
commissaire régional au tourisme
kovy des absences d'algériens ont certes
eu un impact sur l'économie locale
mais le bilan est loin d'être alarmant
selon les statistiques les touristes
algériens d'avant qu'ovide représenter
environ deux millions huit cent mille
personnes
parmi eux un million deux cent mille
transiter par la frontière avec tabarka
nous avons constaté en 2020 une
influence négative sur l'économie de la
région notamment depuis que notre voisin
algérien a fermé ses frontières
les touristes algériens avaient un grand
rôle sur l'économie de notre région
nous avons remarqué que beaucoup de
petits commerces et artisans avait un
contact direct avec ces voyageurs qui
avaient l'habitude de s'arrêter
fréquemment dans leur stand
il souffre aujourd'hui de cette
fermeture alors que les frontaliers des
deux bords espérer une réouverture
prochaine
le gouvernement algérien vient de
décider subitement de durcir les mesures
d'accès à son territoire depuis la
découverte d'un variant sur le sol
tunisien alors que seuls les
travailleurs et les marchandises munis
d'une autorisation de déplacement
pouvaient encore circulé entre les deux
pays
cette nouvelle mesure vient
compliqué la situation déjà très
fragilisé un coup dur supplémentaire
pour des milliers de transfrontalier
déjà durement touchée par la crise du
coronavirus